habt ihr euch jemals gefragt in welchem
land der welt es am meisten regnet nun
nicht so schnell denn dieses mal hat die
antwort absolut nichts mit dem titel
dieses videos zu tun das land in dem es
am meisten regnet heißt colum will das
land des cafés und von shakira aber
außer viel regen hat kolumbien nicht
viel mit unseren heutigen protagonisten
zu tun denn obwohl singapur nicht die
nummer eins auch der regen weltrangliste
ist gehört es dennoch zu den
spitzenreitern es belegt immerhin den 14
platz mit einer durchschnittlichen
niederschlagsmenge von 2400 mm pro jahr
so und an dieser stelle fand ihr sicher
schon an euch zu fragen was dieses video
denn eigentlich sollte wieso steht dem
titel was von wasserknappheit in
singapur wieder nur so klickt oder was
nun ganz und gar nicht klar angesichts
dieser tatsache könnte man meinen dass
singapur viel wasser zur verfügung steht
aber wir haben es in diesen inselstaat
start mit einem ganz besonders
vertrackten problemen zu tun obwohl es
eines der regen reichsten länder der
welt ist leider es trotzdem unter
starker wasserknappheit die zwei
wichtigsten fragen die sich hier stellen
sind also wie um alles in der welt
kriegen die bewohner der löwenstadt das
coolste können dass sie bei solch
massiven regenfällen und ihrer geringen
größe unter wasserknappheit leiden was
zum teufel hat singapur bisher getan und
was gedenkt ist zu tun um dieses problem
zu lösen erinnert ihr euch noch an unser
video über israels wasser wunder falls
nicht werde ich es euch verlinkt falls
ihr das thema wasser genauso spannend
wie wir solltet ihr es nicht passen und
die lösungsansätze für das dringendste
problem ist klein südostasiatischen
stadtstaat sind geben so außergewöhnlich
und erstaunlich design wahrzeichen
namens mary leon ein skurriles
fabelwesen hat loewe hat will jungfrau
der löwenkopf symbolisiert stärke und
furchtlosigkeit und der fisch körper
steht für die verbundenheit mit dem
näher also seid ihr bereit für eine
entdeckungsreise in dieses faszinierende
land dann nichts wie los
[Applaus]
[Musik]
singapur ist nicht nur ein wirklich
faszinierend dass sondern auch
hochgradig interessant das land ein
außerordentlich innovative ort über den
wir auf diese politik berichten wäre
normalerweise über themen wie
rechtssicherheit das wirtschaftsmodell
oder gar die überraschende militärische
schlagkraft dieses herausragendes landes
sprechen dass wir dieses mal einen blick
auf ein ganz anderes thema wasser ok ich
weiß ich bin mir sicher dass viele von
euch in diesem moment tragen aber mag
was zum teufel hat wasser mit politik zu
tun und die sollte es auf diesen kanal
doch geht nun wisst ihr was es hat eine
ganze menge mit ihr zu tun viel mehr als
man vielleicht zunächst annimmt
[Musik]
wasser ist ein lebenswichtiger rohstoff
und bei einem solchen von einem anderen
land abhängig zu sein kann daher
durchaus dem wahrsten wortsinn
existenziell werden singapur ist zwar
eines der länder in denen es am meisten
regnet aber das problem ist das ist auch
eines der am dichtesten besiedelten
länder der welt ist mit etwa fünfeinhalb
millionen einwohner auf einer fläche von
etwas mehr als 700 quadratkilometern
geht es einfach nicht genug platz und
all das benötigte süßwasser so speichern
das in form von regen vom himmel kommt
es ist ja zum beispiel schwer möglich
einen riesigen stau sehen mitten in der
stadt anzulegen insgesamt gibt es in
diesem staat statt 17
wasserauffangbecken aber es überrascht
nicht dass die meisten von ihnen sehr
klein sind und den enormen wasserbedarf
der stadt nicht decken können
[Musik]
genau aus diesem grund ist die
wasserwirtschaft zu einem zentralen
thema in der politik des landes geworden
tatsächlich gilt den gabor ist eines der
ärmsten länder der welt und steht
diesmal auf platz eins der liste 33
länder die bis 2040 extrem durch wasser
armut gefährdet sind natürlich wächst
die stadt dank ihres wirtschaftlichen
wohlstand stetig und damit auch der
bedarf an wasser sie demnach folgendes
an
[Musik]
und es geht nicht nur um die bevölkerung
obwohl sie sich um einen reinen
stadtstaat handelt werden mehr als 55
prozent des gesamten wasserbedarfs von
der wirtschaft und nicht von den
haushalten verbraucht ein anteil der bis
zum jahr 2060 sogar auf 70 prozent
einsteigen soll tja ich habe euch
bereits gesagt dass singapur ständig
wächst und das heißt die industrie der
tourismus und ja sogar die
landwirtschaft vor diesem hintergrund
stellt sich also die frage wie kann die
wasserversorgung in einem land
gewährleistet werden dessen territorium
durch den wachsenden bedarf an wohnungen
industrie hotels und unternehmen aller
art zunehmend unter druck gerät welchen
plan haben sie in einem der reichsten
und wohlhabendsten staaten der welt in
petto genau das sehen wir uns jetzt an
[Applaus]
was der politik
[Musik]
wie bereits erwähnt ist die stadt des
million einer der am stärksten
organisierten dicht besiedelten und vom
wasser abhängigen orte der welt die
kapazität zum bau von infrastruktur ist
stark begrenzt es ist im grunde eine
frage sehr knapper flächen deshalb war
die hitze des im land verbrauchten
wassers aus dem nachbarland malaysia
importiert und genau das ist der punkt
an dem die größte aufregung beginnt hier
sind nämlich die politiker denn die
wasserversorgung in diesem staat start
hängt heute vor allem von einem
langjährigen und seitens singapurs gut
ausgehandelten abkommen ab ein abkommen
mit den behörden des bundesstaates juror
dass der malaysischen zentralregierung
überhaupt nicht gefällt dank des
abkommens mit yoga betreibt in tampere
einen staudamm der es ihnen ermöglicht
täglich etwa 900 millionen liter
unbehandeltes wasser aus dem nachbarland
zu importieren
das problem für die malaysia ist jedoch
der preis die behörden von singapur
haben sich auf eine entschädigung von
das entnommene wasser von drei
malaysischen cent pro 1000 lohnen wasser
verständigt das sind etwa 0,2 prozent
pro 1000 liter der grund warum der preis
so lächerlich klein ist ist dass er
nicht einseitig geändert werden kann das
abkommen das 1962 mit kraft trat und 99
jahre lang gültig es legt fest dass der
preis nach dem ersten 25 jahren nicht
mehr geändert werden kann mit anderen
worten der preis ist seit 1987
unverändert geblieben aber das ist noch
nicht alles das abkommen enthält eine
klausel die singapore dazu verpflichtet
bis zu zwei prozent des importierten
wassers nach der aufbereitung
herstellung der trinkwasser eignung zu
einem preis von 50 cent pro 1000
gallonen zurückzuverkaufen
[Musik]
mit anderen worten singapur importiert
1000 gallonen unbehandeltes wasser für
13 und verkauft 1000 behandeltes wasser
für 50 cent außerdem sieht das abkommen
keine preisanpassung aufgrund von
installationen oder ähnlichem vor und
das ist schon ein verdammt gutes
geschäft ist singapur meint ihr nicht
singapur vertritt klar und konsequent
die position dass malaysia das recht auf
eine überprüfung des wasserpreises dem
abkommen von 1962 verloren hat wie ihr
euch vorstellen könnt hat all dies in
malaysia zu enormer frustration geführt
kein wunder wenn das abkommen bedeutet
dass singapur sein wasser quasi
geschenkt bekommt
es kann also zu einer menge
diplomatischer konflikte zwischen den
beiden ländern wegen des wassers kommen
und das erklärt natürlich auch
schlagzeilen wie diese machen was da
schreibt die kapo wieder auf und nimmt
das abkommen von 1962 lächerlich aber
wartet mal denn die vereinbarung gilt
nicht für immer und ewig
über euch gesagt haben hat das abkommen
eine laufzeit von 99 jahren was bedeutet
dass singapur im jahr 2069 sein recht
verlieren wird wasser zu solch
vorteilhaften bedingungen zu importieren
außerdem herrscht in singapur eine
regelrechte festungs mentalität es hat
einst für seine größte unglaublich
schlagkräftiges militär und sie haben
bereits in den früheren video
ausführlich darüber gesprochen ich lass
euch natürlich verlinken auf grund
dieser philosophie der wehrhaftigkeit
eine selbstständigkeit zu der sie auch
allen grund haben und die ihnen wirklich
in den knochen steckt wollen sie in
einer so wichtigen angelegenheit die
wasser nicht von einem drittel an
abhängig sein sie betrachten dieser
abhängigkeit als strategische schwäche
und auch als ein problem der nationalen
sicherheit denn wer weiß schon was
langfristig im nachbarland mal leise ja
passieren könnte klar bis zum jahr 2061
ist ist noch eine ganze weile aber bei
all dem käufer aus kuala lumpur wäre
auch ich vorsichtig and singapore
bereitet man sich auf jeden fall schon
auf den worst case for die regierung
singapurs hat sich deswegen das
grundlegende ziel gesetzt spätestens
2060 die selbstversorgung mit assad
brechen dies ist eine gigantische
herausforderung für die der stadtstaat
an den plan ins leben gerufen hat der
die reduzierung des verbrauchs die
nutzung jedes einzelnen trocken ist
natürlich die fähigkeit sauberes wasser
selbst zu produzieren kombiniert ziel
ist eine nachhaltige stabile
wirtschaftlich tragbare und potenziell
unbegrenzte versorgung mit süßwasser zu
erreichen und möchtet ihr wissen wie sie
das alles schaffen wollen dann mal los
[Musik]
die vier wasserhähne des löwen
wie ich euch bereits eingangs gesagt
habe ist es ein problem dass es in
singapur war seite regnet es aber nicht
viel lust bares grundwasser gibt und
auch keine großen süßwasservorkommen
vorhanden sind es versteht sich von
selbst dass es dort keinen platz für
große stauseen gibt um dieses problem zu
lösen was ihr die derzeitige
wasserbewirtschaftung auf den
sogenannten vier nationalen wasserhähnen
das heißt den vier wichtigsten
wasserquellen des landes die erste davon
basiert auf dem sammeln von wasser aus
lokalen einzugsgebieten um ein netzwerk
von meatco reservoirs und stauseen zu
speisen
[Musik]
um diese wasserquelle zu verbessern
forderte singapur bereits seit 1972 den
sogenannten water masterplan dieser plan
bestand darin alle möglichen
einsatzgebiete und reservoirs zu
identifizieren um regenwasser zu sammeln
und für die wasserversorgung zu nutzen
dank dieses plans wurden neue kleine
stauseen angelegt so dass sich die
gesamtzahl der stausee auf immerhin 17
erhöht hat darunter ist so ein großer
städtischer chaussee der das herz des
stadtstaates mit seinem berühmten
wahrzeichen der marina bay umspült
ja so sieht's aus so überraschend ist
auch klingen mag seit 2008 wurde die
riesige lagune ist ingres historische
bucht in welcher der mary und sein
wasser verspritzt in 1 fuß
wasserreservoir umgewandelt den zweiten
nationalen wasserhahn handel preis
erklärt aus malaysia importiertes wasser
eine quelle die voraussichtlich im jahr
2061 versiegen wird schließlich an
dritter und vierter stelle stehen was
ein salz und in newport und hier wird es
wirklich interessant denn diese beiden
einheimischen quellen sind der schlüssel
zum erreichen der wasser auf
[Musik]
das gilt vor allem für new bot dazu
deutschlands für die neue wasser nur
water ist eines der fortschrittlichsten
wasseraufbereitungssystem der welt und
singapur ist wichtigste waffe um die
wasserversorgung zu sichern es besteht
aus einer vierstufigen bild rage system
welches abwasser in trinkwasser um
landet zunächst durch läuft das wasser
eine konventionelle kläranlage dann
durchläuft das eine zweite stufe die aus
einem mikro und ultrafiltration system
durch extrem feine membran besteht die
dritte stufe besteht aus einer umkehr
osmose einem druck reinigungssystem das
unerwünschte moleküle johnen große
partikel so die salze und mineralien
entfernt und als vierte barriere wird
schließlich drei violettes licht
eingesetzt um das wasser von bakterien
zu desinfizieren
das alles klingt nach einem komplexen
system aber in wirklichkeit ist ist gar
nicht so komplex denn singapur gibt es
bereits fünf new yorker anlagen zur
abwasseraufbereitung und eine sechste
wird bis 2025 in betrieb gehen und ihr
fragt euch sicher ob man dieses wasser
problemlos trinken kann und die antwort
ist ja es ist wasser das für den
menschlichen verzehr vollkommen geeignet
ist tatsächlich hat das bieterverfahren
bereits mehr als 150.000
wissenschaftliche tests bestanden wie zu
seiner zulassung durch die
weltgesundheitsorganisation und seine
einstufung als ultra sauberes absolut
sicheres trinkwasser geführt haben
[Musik]
trotzdem wird nur water hauptsächlich
separat als nutzwasser geliefert vor
allem industrielle und gewerbliche
zwecke oder für dinge wie kühlsystem von
klimaanlagen in industrie größe und
glaubt mir es inga pur ist die
klimaanlage ein sehr wichtiges gerät
aber wartet einen moment denn auch hier
tut sich noch viel ein teil des wassers
wird zur ergänzung der
trinkwasserversorgung der haushalte
verwendet indem es mit wasser aus
stauseen gemischt wird und natürlich
wird angesichts der bestehenden
einschränkungen das durch jungmutter
gereinigt wasser für den gebrauch in
haushalten immer wichtiger es wird
erwartet dass dies bis 2060 mehr als die
hälfte des gesamten wasserverbrauchs
ausmachen wird und so weit ist noch
nicht nach israel gekommen und dann
hätten wir schließlich noch wasser
entsalzung dieses dritte nationale
quelle ist nicht so neu es gibt sie
schon seit langer zeit
[Musik]
singapur verfügt derzeit über vier ins
anlagen die einen durchaus hohen
prozentsatzes wasserbedarfs decken
können es wird erwartet dass bis 2060
bis zu 30 prozent des nationalen bedarfs
durch and science das wasser gedeckt
werden können zusammen mit dem wasser
aus denen neue wasserwerken wird
erwartet dass damit bis zu 85 prozent
des nationalen wasserverbrauchs gedeckt
werden und darüber hinaus erhebliche
frischwasser reserven im hauptspeicher
des servers ist das nicht unglaublich
ein land mit einem derart winzigen
territorium schafft sich einen nicht für
möglich gehaltenen wasserreichtum es
wird zu einer wahren wasser großmacht
aber moment mal wenn sie die beiden die
teller israel und singapur betrachten
scheint es doch eher so zu sein dass
wenn wir von wasserknappheit in anderen
ländern sprechen es sich in wirklichkeit
um eine gewaltiges missmanagement mit
wasser handelt eine fast endlose
wasserverschwendung
[Musik]
tatsache ist dass singapur mit diesem
plan hofft bis zum jahr 2061 wenn der
vertrag über den wasser import aus
malaysia ausläuft die selbstversorgung
zu erreichen zu diesem zeitpunkt wird
erwartet dass man von den vier
derzeitigen quellen 03 brauchen wird
natürlich ist dieser plan mit einem
riesigen aufwand und erheblichen
investitionen verbunden und das sorgt
sich auch beim bürger aus singapur will
den wasserpreis innerhalb von zwei
jahren um 30 prozent erhöhen
andererseits könnte es dem davor in
naher zukunft ein wichtiger exporteur
von wassermanagement und
wasseraufbereitung technologien werden
stellt euch nur vor was diese technik in
ländern wie saudi arabien katar oder
sogar an einem ort mit so katastrophalen
wassermanagement wie indien wert sein
könnte singapurs wie auch israels
technologie und know how haben das
potenzial zu einem gigantischen
exportschlager zu werden aber was soll
man sagen wenn jemand weiß wie man geld
verdient dann sind das doch die menschen
in singapur und israel licht war und in
diesem fall verdienen sie die reichtümer
sogar mit einer sehr guten sache im
tausch gegen wohlstand und frisches
wasser für alle aber jetzt seid ihr erst
mal an der reihe glaubt ihr dass der
technologische fortschritt die
wasserprobleme der welt in zukunft lösen
wird und damit auch die möglichen
politischen herausforderungen die sich
daraus ergeben könnten wird die
technologie aus singapur das ende der
wasserknappheit bringen die immer sind
sie auf eure beiträge und diskussionen
zu diesem thema schon sehr gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses video gefallen
hat und ihr vielleicht auch etwas
gelernt habt was ja gibt es mit einem
leichten und freunden vergesst nicht
dass aber mit glöckchen und keines
unseren videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine spende von euch mit der uns
hilft dieses projekt weiterzuführen den
paypal link dazu findet ihr wie immer in
der beschreibung der dem video was gut
und bis bald
[Musik]